we're establishing where the product
rule comes from okay and many parts of
it I'm not intuitive at all at least not
to us right it's a very complicated
problem like the result when it comes
out it's so beautifully nicely super
fire but to get there it's a bit
involved so here's one of the important
pieces we need we need to develop a
better grounding on our notation here
okay because we've kind of been we have
a reasonable understanding of it but I'm
going to introduce some kind of new
symbols kind of new that we need to have
a look at a simple example that to
understand so why I cook is x squared I
keep coming back to this guy I'm very
faithful servant okay
when you consider this function okay and
by the way this and this they are the
same these brackets don't mean like we
see this is function notation right so Y
is a function of X and I'm defining it
as X square now I want to consider what
happens to this at for instance well
let's just pick a value like say 3 so Y
of 3 means Y of 3 means I'm taking what
happens to my when X is equal to 3 right
so another way of saying this is when x
equals 3 y equals just leaving off that
beginning with y equals what 3 squared
that's not ok now the reason why I draw
that out okay so if I say it right with
this 3 and there's nine is if I think
about this from like the limits point of
view right the idea is to let you go
forward a little bit have a little bit
of run and therefore you get a little
bit of rise right now let me illustrate
that to you numerically ok if I think
about going just you know we had H and
we said there's this distance and we
want it to go to zero okay what if we
knew what H was what if we define H to
be like I don't know
whatever 100 0.01 this is a small little
distance right so the secant the secret
if I were to draw it if I could do it to
scale would be on you know those two
points on the Cicotte the two points of
intersection will be very very close
together
there will be that fire-pot okay now
when I go ahead and evaluate this
numerically what
happens okay I could just say well it's
the three point zero one squared I could
do that okay but I want to illustrate
something else I'm going to write it
like this I'm going to keep this which
is the x value that I'm particularly
looking at and this which is that H
right that little change okay I'm going
to keep them separate right what happens
on the next slide just humor me for a
second okay it's a perfect square line
it's going to be yeah well it's going to
be um it's an A plus B whole square so
I'm going to get a square plus 2 a B
plus 0.01 square which is 0.001 [ __ ]
doing my decimal places right you happy
with that sir what is this do you notice
okay what I've got this 3 squared that's
really actually where I started right
and then I moved forward a little bit
should
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah zero point zero
zero zero one one one ten thousand so
right yeah okay good it's always tricky
out to the desert place isn't it good
okay so that makes this this yeah you
happy with that it's still essentially
the same thing now what does this mean
we just made I now want to replace this
and I need some I need some decent
language myself okay before we were
happy to say H H is this little thing
here right it's that little distance you
go forward so that you can actually
measure a gradient because you need run
don't you okay but now what I've got is
I've got a little distance horizontally
and then I have this thing now what is
this correspond to now I'm just gonna do
this completely off scale because
otherwise you weren't gonna see it right
I've gone forward all right I've gone
forward 0.01 for an x value there's a
0.01 okay and so there's my new x value
now when I go forward horizontally that
corresponds to going up a little bit
very clear right this is nine point zero
six zero one right the scales ridiculous
okay because you can't see another one's
better I've gone horizontally that way
which corresponds to vertically that way
okay now before I just had an H over
here but I want to get a language that
says well one of them is horizontal and
one of them is vertical it's just a
little change for both okay
so set of coin is just age right I'm
going to say I want this to be a small
change in X I'm gonna call it Delta X
Delta that's the Greek letter yeah don't
say ax
that's that 0.01 there and so it
corresponding I'm gonna call this Delta
one it's that little change it's a
different number right it's not the same
number is that it's not even you know
why of 0.01 it's just it just it's a
different note okay a change in it so
now let me write this line
for any point rather than just this
particular point in this particular
distance right I want you know for some
point plus a little bit Delta X what
you're going to get is your original Y
of X see that there's my there's my
point three I now want to think about it
anywhere any value of x and then you're
going to be changing a little bit in why
does that make sense
ah now I can go one step further and I
can really say like Y of X I don't need
to say Y thanks that's really just why
is it so okay this is just my notation
to remember that's actually a function
it changes it's not just a constant
number okay but Y of X plus Delta X if I
put that in I'm gonna get y plus Delta Y
okay you're happy with that there's this
notation now what this equips us to do
is to think of the Delta X and the Delta
Y as the two pieces I rubbed it off our
first principles dy on DX right is the
limit now I don't have an H any wonder
why right I don't have an H approaching
0
what I've substituted for H is this guy
this is H so I've got Delta X now little
distance it's approaching 0 different
label that's always now what I have over
here remember I have no HS anymore but
that's ok I have a name for the rise and
I have a name for the run okay so I've
got Delta Y rise over 1 Delta Y on Delta
X so what's the difference between these
two things okay
this this is an actual distance that
vanishes away and then this is the
result of making that distance vanish
away this is going from the secant to
the tangent as it were that's the
difference between deltas and D okay
Delta's it's like an actual distance it
has to be something whereas this is like
what if it completely disappeared okay
does that make sense so far
good okay now we get a kind of deer but
it stood for Delta in that particular
case where Delta is going to zero right
now it behaves kind of differently when
it actually is zero right so that's why
I distinguish between these two and
that's critically important in G that as
you say